immer neue reisewarnungen da steigt er
am ende gar keiner mehr durch und das
möchte ich klären mit dem tv anwalt
arndt kempgens auch heute wieder ist
dazu geschaltet aus gelsenkirchen hallo
herr kempkens berlin beim urlaub hat man
so langsam wieder im dunkeln wo kann ich
überhaupt noch hinfahren wo gibt es
keine reisewarnung der eindruck es wird
immer kleinteiliger es werden städte als
reisewarnung herausgegeben aber auch
einzelne region das wird doch jetzt ihre
kompliziert was sagen sie dazu
es wird wirklich kompliziert dass da
kann ich sie wirklich nur bestätigen wir
haben ja im grunde genommen die ganze
zeit gefordert es soll flexibel bleiben
es soll
einzelfallregelungen geben und es soll
quasi auf jedes land auf jede
anforderung einzelnen reagiert werden
das hatten sich eigentlich alle
gewünscht und jetzt kommt diese
situation aber das macht es natürlich
für reisende noch viel schwieriger weil
man sozusagen weil jeder reisebuchung
immer natürlich auswerten das auswärtige
amt und die homepage im auge behalten
muss und man muss fallen so ein bisschen
in zukunft denken was passiert nächste
woche nächsten monat wenn meine reise
angetreten werden soll also die
situation ist nicht einfacher geworden
aber vielleicht gerechter folgen doch
vielleicht mal die länder durch gehen
also eine ganz klare reisetipp ist
natürlich deutschland da können sie
leicht hotels auch wieder stornieren
viele hotels bieten natürlich auch
kostenlose stornierungen an
dann gibt es natürlich italien
österreich die nachbarländer dänemark
niederlande polen ist auch natürlich ein
ganz heißer tipp da auch an der ostsee
da sprechen viele leute deutsch aber
ansonsten muss man doch um seinen urlaub
letztlich banken denn diese aufhebung
der pauschale reisewarnung die das
auswärtige amt angekündigt hat da muss
ich ja auch abwarten sollte ich einen
vielleicht exotisches reiseziel gebucht
haben was wird daraus besteht dort eine
reisewarnung weiter oder wie sehen sie
das
also man kann im grunde genommen sagen
hier exotischer desto kritischer wird
die situation sicherlich und vor allen
dingen ganz wichtig dass man sich vorher
auch über den krankenversicherungsschutz
gedanken macht das hat man eigentlich
vorher also zumindest aus meiner
erfahrung oder für mich eigentlich habe
mir nie so richtig gedanken darum
gemacht
wenn ich in ein fremdes land fahre weil
man eigentlich so gar kein so besonderes
risiko bewusst seien hatte das muss sich
unbedingt ändern
man muss also vorher schon überlegen was
ist denn wenn ich im ausland tatsächlich
erkranken oder in quarantäne muss und
tatsächlich ausweisen kann und dort
bleiben muss beispielsweise möchte ich
das eigentlich und wenn so etwas
passiert wie bin ich rechtlich
versicherungsrechtlich abgesichert das
muss man unbedingt vorher klären damit
man sozusagen einen schritt voraus ist
und wenn man das dann geklärt hat und
für mich für sich durchdacht hat dann
sollte man überlegen will ich jetzt
tatsächlich noch in dieses land fahren
und das muss man eben genau überlegen